aider les élèves à comprendre le système
des médias à former leur jugement
critique c'est une des missions de cette
semaine à l'école et c'est votre mission
à vous la professeur emmanuel roussel de
ce collège qui est à brazey-en-plaine
qu'on vous fait finalement bien ça
commence dès la sixième en fait je
prends les classes de 6e une heure par
quinzaine et on commence à parler un peu
des médias pendant la semaine de la
presse évidemment je mets en place le
kiosque et puis on fait des petites
séances autour de la presse diversité
pluralité de la presse et ce genre de
choses est forcément aussi quelques
exercices doux la venue de marion et
lucide qui sont avec nous ce matin vous
leur avez demandé quoi avant que les
écoute on leur a demandé de préparer une
petite chronique pour l'émission est
donc l ont ils ont réfléchi en classe
entière sur la thématique et ensuite il
a fallu évidemment choisir l'angle de
cette chronique alors que l'angle marion
en fait on va parler de la monétisation
sur youtube
comment gagne de l'argent ouais sur lucy
voit aussi expliqué qu est-ce qu on peut
trouver et qu'est ce que c'est youtube
d'un corps j'ai envie de vous poser la
question à toutes les deux là je me
tourne vers vous marion et lucie qu'est
ce que c'est youtube youtube c'est un
site web sur lequel on peut regarder
commenter et partager des vidéos
il a été créé en février 2005 a racheté
par google en 2006 on peut y trouver
différentes catégories de vidéos il ya
les tutoriels cd vidéo qui explique
comment faire des choses par exemple en
cuisine bricolage maquillage
alors ça c'est vrai je me tourne vers la
prof là que de plus en plus de jeunes
font des tutos 1 vous pourrez pas passer
à côté et ça faut vous dire que dans les
coulisses de cette émission actuellement
il ya des jeunes qui sont en train de
nous filmer de votre collègue justement
on retrouvera certainement ça sur une
plate forme chez vous et puis on vous
mettra les bons liens sur france 3
points est ferme donc vous le disait
fort justement j'ai du mal à vous voyez
on peut se tutoyer marion allez on se
tutoie alors marion dis-moi ya plusieurs
catégories de vidéos c'est ça sur
youtube il ya aussi des vidéos
informatives sur différents thèmes quand
même les sciences ou l'histoire d'autres
sur les jeux où on les présentait on
explique les solutions et on trouve
aussi des blagues et des vidéos
d'humoriste alors s'il y en a beaucoup
des blagues vidéo d'humoristes ans et
échanger les filles
oui
pas se le cacher tout le monde peut
publier des vidéos sur sa toiture et
publier des vidéos sur cette plateforme
les plateformes qui les personnes qui
font des vidéos sont appelés dès
youtuber ils peuvent commencer très
jeune par exemple nous en avons dans la
classe la majorité fait des vidéos sur
les jouets peuple j'ai entendu marion il
ya quelqu'un de la classe qui fait des
vidéos c'est ça il s'appellerait pas les
rucks par hasard si alors ça c'est la
magie de la télé nous sommes allés
chercher justement ce que feneyrols
votre camarade de classe à
brazey-en-plaine au collège regarder
avec moi les rucks sur youtube heures
ils sont venus sans votre soirée
non on a perdu ses filaments rouges il a
l'air drôlement sympa votre camarade de
jeu là il fait ça tout le temps en
caisse enfin pas forcément aux classes
parce que la poste ne pas être d'accord
bon il y en a qui font aussi des vidéos
humoristiques marion oui la plupart des
youtuber font des vidéos par plaisir
mais il y en a qui font des vidéos
qu'ils en font leur métier
c'est le cas de norman qui fait des
vidéos humoristiques ça aussi on connaît
norman on pouvait pas passer à côté d'un
extrait norman vous êtes d'accord
alors on va regarder ensemble dans 9
heures 50 le matin normal alors j'ai pas
non plus comment vous comporter au
magasin mais moi je pense que je suis
pas toujours le client idéal quand je
fais tomber un produit et ya pas de
témoins bah je ramasse pas j'aime bien
reposé les produits au mauvais endroit
j'essaye toujours de passer à la caisse
- des articles avec 11
parfois je mange le produit avant de
l'avoir payé et je suis en stress comme
si j'ai braqué moulin
et puis alors là on est franchement sur
duperoux parce que pour faire une vidéo
marion c'est pas si facile que ça
beaucoup de la préparation enfin
installer le matériel nécessaire
c'est-à-dire les éclairages la caméra le
micro mais il faut aussi préparer le
sujet de la vidéo enregistrée est enfin
publié son travail sur le site est monté
nos camarades par exemple il met 15 20
minutes a monté une vidéo de deux trois
minutes moi beaucoup ouais en fonction
du youtuber et de la vidéo on peut en
faire son métier lui si on peut vivre
200 m oui d'abord tout le monde ne gagne
pas forcément d'argent sur youtube pour
commencer à en gagner faut au minimum
1000 abonnés et 4000 heures de
visionnage sur les douze derniers mois
c'est énorme quand même ça fait 80
milles vidéo de 3 minutes et donc si on
arrive à ça on peut on peut activer la
monétisation c'est à dire qu'on demande
à youtube de nous payer pour les vidéos
ouais il y alors deux choix soit youtube
mais de la pub sur la vidéo
en gros bas c'est comme à la télé une
cuve démarre avant ou au milieu de la
vidéo mais c'est pas forcément les mêmes
pub soit youtube paye en fonction du
nombre de vues de chaque vidéo par
exemple youtube heures qui fait 8000 vue
sur et demi une vidéo gagnera 8 euros
soit un euro pour me lever 1 euro pour
me lever
j'imagine que quentin youtuber devient
probable à cette marque forcément qu'ils
s'intéressent à nous parce que vous les
jeunes vous regardez après tout cela du
commerce
quant à youtube heures devient connu
certaines marques le contact pour le
sponsoriser il devra alors parlé d'un
produit qui ont renvoyé dans une vidéo
et en échange d'argent en échange
d'argent
il va faire quelque chose de très très
bien je ne suis ni resale un placement
de produit non non en tant qu'abonné bas
on trouve que parfois il y en a trop et
trop de placement tu le placement il ya
aussi certains adultes qui filment leurs
enfants et qui en profite pour gagner de
l'argent
ce qui est sûr c'est qu'on peut trouver
les vidéos à notre goût suffit d'aller
les chercher pour moi je préfère que
vous regardez quand même un petit peu la
télévision les filles vous regarderez un
vent très bien
en tout cas merci d'avoir été avec nous
avec le collège de brazey-en-plaine
merci à vous madame la professeure de
nous avoir permis d'accueillir ses
élèves avec leur sourire c'est pas un
exercice forcément facile facile dans
les conditions que nous avons dans
laquelle nous avons pu réaliser cette
chronique ce matin merci à vous la
semaine de la presse à l'école ça
continue encore pendant quelques heures
sur france 3 évidemment